soccer Samba and the Summer Olympics
that's what you think of when you think
of Brazil but lately it's more like Zika
recession and a political crisis that
could have the president impeached
before the Summer Games even begin
millions of people have hit the streets
demanding President Dilma Rousseff's
impeachment and proceedings have already
begun many believe she's linked to the
biggest corruption scandal in the
country centered around the state-owned
oil company Petrobras basically people
received kickbacks in exchange for
contracts even though Dilma hasn't been
formally charged members of her party
the moderate left Workers Party have
been including former President Luiz
inácio Lula da Silva Dilma actually
nominated Lula as chief of staff some
say to protect him from prosecution
ouch but the political crisis runs
deeper than Dilma after all 353
officials from all parties are facing
corruption and criminal charges but you
wouldn't know that by reading the
headlines Brazil versus the president is
a common slogan being pushed by
mainstream Brazilian media they focused
selectively on Dilma's party and left
other problems behind it's led some to
accuse the media of inciting a coup and
if you look at who runs major news
outlets it's not hard to see how their
agenda has clashed with the Workers
Party there are five families who own
70% of brazil's mainstream media
they've been part of the country's
wealthy and ruling elite for decades and
are linked to the military dictatorship
that took over after a coup in 1964
Brazil was run by a dictatorship for 21
years that restricted freedom of speech
and political opposition both Dilma and
Lula were political prisoners during
that time then there's a role of the
courts in all of this the lead
investigator in the Petrobras scandal
judge Sergio Moro hasn't exactly played
an impartial role recently he leaks a
tapped phone call between Dilma and Lula
in the calls Dilma refers to a document
appointing Lula as chief of staff saying
he should quote use it in case of
necessity
some say it's damning evidence others
questioned Morrow's leaking of the
recording without due process and
another judge recently put an injunction
on Lula's appointment as chief of staff
a guy who was also seen taking selfies
at an anti-government rally one thing to
remember is that Brazil is a country
with major economic inequality political
preference tends to fall along class and
racial lines that could be why the
majority of protesters demanding Dilma's
departure are both whiter and wealthier
this photo of a protesting couple with
their dog and nanny has gone viral it's
perhaps emblematic of the political
divide Dilma's Workers Party has focused
mostly on helping the poor their welfare
programs help 23 million Brazilians out
of poverty within 10 years but lately
it's not just the media and
conservatives who are fed up with the
ruling party many critique Dilma from
the left angry at the recently passed
anti-terrorism law and massive
overspending on things like the World
Cup so should Dilma be impeached and who
would take her place if she is the vice
president who belongs to a different
party is also under scrutiny for
corruption and the guy below him has
been charged with accepting 40 million
dollars worth of bribes so between that
and the questionable actions of
high-level judges what's actually at
stake in Brazil may be democracy itself
you